I had no joy
[Music]
[Music]
things aren't looking too good for
auradon and some might even say that
they had it coming after all imprisoning
a bunch of innocent people is a surefire
way to create a revolution but there's
still hope for auradon and a happily
ever after might still be on the horizon
keep watching to find out what will
happen after descendant 3 under attack
on the surface where dawn might seem
like the perfect place to live but when
you dig a little deeper you find out
that its foundation is built on fear
over 20 years ago beast and fairy
godmother resurrected villains and
sentenced them to life imprisonment on
the Isle of the Lost but they didn't
stop there
they took things a step further by
imprisoning sidekicks and petty thieves
as well these unfortunate souls
eventually had kids of their own who
were also forced to live out their days
in exile this is totally unfair which is
why Hades is making a lot of sense right
about now king Ben is slowly trying to
introduce BK's into auradon but the ones
who are being left behind are growing
increasingly jealous and bitter before
we dive into what will happen after
descendants 3 let's take a look at what
will most likely happen before the
franchise wraps up we think that the vks
will be forced to choose sides and that
some of them will fight alongside the
villains while others help out mal and
her friends
either way the V case will be showing
their true colors and since most of them
are nice people who are unrightfully in
prison the people of auradon might be
shocked to find out just how many BK's
are actually good
when they imprisoned me here but after
being caged up for years so what will
happen after the third and final
descendants film
well first starters we think the Isle of
the Lost will be destroyed
or at the very least the barrier will be
permanently taken down some people might
choose to remain on the Isle while
others will plead auradon as soon as
possible
King Fang will choose to honor the
people of the Isle of the Lost by
creating a museum in their name this
museum will be located on the Isle and
it'll pay tribute to everyone who lived
on it future generations will visit this
Isle during field trips and learn all
about how not to roll a kingdom
sorry Balon B's segregation is never the
answer
although some people will choose to stay
on the Isle most of its population will
move to the United States of auradon
those who were born with royal titles
will be given land as peace offerings
and et will finally become the princess
she was born to be all of the BK's will
attend Oregon press and now Evie Jay and
Carlos will help the B case get settled
in you must look at that ember it's game
over
Belle beast and fairy godmother were so
scared of their enemies using magic that
they need magic somewhat illegal but we
think that the new auradon will be a lot
more inclusive students will learn to
use magic for the greater good now might
even become a teacher at auradon prep
and teacher students how to brew potions
and cast spells now C give it a bottle
correct by now you're probably wondering
what will happen to the evil villains
who don't want to play nice well for
starters
they'll have to be rehabilitated instead
of imprisoning everyone who doesn't see
eye to eye with the king and queen of
auradon those who try to repel will have
to undergo therapy at villain
rehabilitation center Jain and fairy
godmother will help villains let go of
the past and try to get to the root of
their feelings and they'll have their
hands full with Audrey
but of course rules were made to be
broken so every once in a while a
villain will strike but this time around
students will know how to use magic to
defend themselves and the newly
instituted Oregon Police Academy will
deal with these villains win the
come we would love to see Ben Malley DJ
and Carlos graduate from auradon prep
can you just imagine the songs they
would sing we'd love to see them
throwing their hats in the air but with
so much to cover in descendents 3 we're
not exactly sure if we'll get to see our
favorite vks graduate so it's possible
that their graduation ceremony will
happen after the 3 quo still we're
hoping that the d3 cast is going to
shoot a few music videos and release
them as bonus tracks if you'd like to
see mouths class graduation leave a
graduation cap emoji in the comment
section but if there's one scene we
absolutely need to see it's Malin Ben's
royal wedding in the official descendant
3 trailer we see King been proposing to
mal he asks her if she will be his Queen
and Audrey totally flips out descendants
fans would love to see a happily ever
after so we're hoping to see mal walk
down the aisle we'd love to see her
wedding dress too and we're certain that
Edie's already begun designing it
if Hades turns out to be a good guy he
would totally walk his daughter down the
aisle this villain and hero wedding
would help auradon be a more inclusive
country while encouraging its population
to intermingle but with so much ground
left to cover we don't know if
descendants 3 will end with a royal
wedding or not so we're hoping that
Kenny Ortega and his crew are going to
release a short film once the three
quill wraps up a lot is going to change
after descendants 3 despite doing their
best to create a safe and happy country
fell and bees totally missed the mark
they unrightfully imprison children and
didn't see anything wrong with it now
that Ben and mal will become the king
and queen of auradon it's safe to say
that a new and better era is about to
commence we can't wait to see what
happens in descendant 3 do you guys
think that Hades is going to redeem
himself by the end of the movie or are
you convinced that Mouse dad is as
wicked as Maleficent sound off in the
comments section below for more videos
about your favorite movies and TV shows
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up while
you're at it thanks for watching see you
next time
[Music]